[Musique]
délai dans les demandes de passeport
retard pour les visas retard pour les
déclarations de revenus programme de
soutien aux agriculteurs qui seront
touchés également donc cette grève
depuis minuit hier soir aura des
conséquences sur les citoyens est-ce que
elle risque de durer un bon bout de
temps quelles sont les espoirs de
règlement on va parler aux deux parties
ce soir ils vont barrières qui vivent
président exécutif régional de
l'Alliance de la fonction publique du
Canada vous êtes section au Québec
monsieur barrière bonsoir et bonsoir
Mona Fortier qui sera avec nous qui est
avec nous qui est président du Conseil
du Trésor merci d'être l'homme madame
Fortier merci je commence avec vous
monsieur barrière on a montré tout à
l'heure et je vais les remontrer les
demandes syndicales bon pour le salaire
13,5 of patronales 9%. d'abord première
question de base est-ce que ça négocie à
17h ça ne malheureusement ça ne
négociait pas hier un point de presse on
a invité le Conseil du Trésor à revenir
le plus rapidement possible
malheureusement nos équipes de
négociation qui sont encore à Ottawa
présentement et ce jusqu'à samedi et
attendent toujours le retour des des
agents de du Conseil du Trésor ok sont
dans une salle puis il y a personne en
face effectivement bon
vos demandes salariales l'écart c'est
rétrécie quand même parce qu'au départ
il y avait un écart monstrueux il y a eu
du progrès de fait dans parlons
simplement du salaire là mais
définitivement écoutez dans les deux
dernières semaines de négociation il y a
eu plus de progrès que dans les deux
dernières années bon parce que je dois
vous rappeler que les contrôles et
conventions collectives sont terminées
depuis juin 20-21 donc la dernière
augmentation de nos membres remontent à
juin 2020 et on va se rappeler que de
juin 20-21 à 20-22 l'inflation est à son
pic à 8.3 donc ce qui est ce qui est
très actuellement c'est qu'on négocie
rétroactivement
si on négocierait pour les trois
prochaines années avec le taux que la
Banque du Canada ne mentionne mais on
serait favorable au 9%. mais
actuellement nos gens on a diminution de
leur pouvoir d'achat de plus de 12%
actuellement
si je me trompe beaucoup plus important
et quand même réduit le de 9 à 13 il y a
pas un océan entre les deux là
effectivement on est proche je demeure
encore optimiste j'avais mis de l'eau
dans votre vin mettez-vous de l'eau dans
votre vin du côté de l'Alliance
absolument on le fait on a on s'est
entendu sur certains articles de laisser
tomber donc on est prêt à entendre une
offre globale du conseil de trésor on
est disponible et on les attend est-ce
que je me trompe monsieur barrière ou le
télétravail devient un enjeu très
important dans cette négociation là il y
a beaucoup de vos membres qui veulent
rester en télétravail la partie
patronale le gouvernement dit nous on
aimerait bien au minimum deux jours que
vous reveniez est-ce que ça c'est pas la
la nouvelle zone de négociation entre
les patrons et les syndicats aujourd'hui
je pense que autant pour l'Alliance de
la fonction publique autant que le
Conseil du Trésor autant pour les
entreprises c'est maintenant une
nouvelle réalité pour les 120 000
fonctionnaires ou les 35000 employés de
l'agence de revenus c'est devenu un
enjeu extrêmement important on érigit
présentement avec une politique et cette
politique a le très mal vieilli
considérant là toute la technologie que
avancée dans les toits et quatre
dernières années ce qu'on demande c'est
tout simplement que le télétravail
devienne des articles dans la convention
collective pour avoir des paramètres
clairs parce que Madame manoeuvre
Fortier le sait présentement il y a des
sous ministres qui disent le télétravail
est aussi efficace sinon mieux que le
travail en présentiel on n'est pas
contre le travail en présentiel on n'est
pas contre le travail vous contre le
fait d'imposer des normes par exemple
deux jours minimum par semaine et vous
comptez vous trouvez ça correct on est
on est contre d'une façon unilatérale et
arbitraire telle que Madame monoportée
non c'est pas exagéré mais écoutez
monsieur roi si quelqu'un qui fait du
service à clientèle au téléphone 8h au
téléphone avec 8 à 10 secondes entre les
appels qui soit à la maison ou qu'il
soit au bureau quelle est la différence
donc c'est vraiment une des un enjeu
important vous dites nos membres ont
connu ça et pour certains ils veulent
pas revenir en arrière
on est en faveur d'une formule hybride
et on est surtout une sur une formule
pour s'adapter à chaque besoin de
département et à chaque besoin de chacun
des ministères parce que chaque
ministère a des besoins extrêmement
différents donc ce qu'on veut c'est tout
simplement d'établir des paramètres
clairs dans la convention collective et
non de laisser ça aller à toi dans une
politique malveillée et que chaque
gestionnaire peut l'interpréter de la
façon qui veut ce qu'on veut que ça soit
clair pour tout le monde autant pour les
gestionnaires que pour les syndicats
parce que présentement ce n'est pas bien
rigide bon très bien télétravail un
enjeu donc important merci beaucoup
monsieur barrière on va se reparler Mona
Fortier président du Conseil du Trésor
est avec nous un enfant qui bonsoir
bonsoir merci de me recevoir ce soir
première question pourquoi vous n'êtes
pas à la table là le syndicat venait de
l'entendre dit nous on les attend on
boit du café tout seul je pense que il
faut quand même s'assurer dire qu'on est
à la table il y a des conversations qui
se passent
développement mon équipe est en train de
travailler très fort je sais que il y a
quatre tables qui sont en discussion et
il y a la table commune ensuite il y a
également la médiation avec l'Agence du
revenu donc il y a beaucoup de
conversations qui se passe il faut dire
qu'au cours des deux dernières semaines
les quatre tables et la table commune
ont eu beaucoup de négociations puis
l'objectif contente évidemment d'arriver
et je pense qu'on va y arriver parce que
je suis optimiste et confiante avoir une
entente qui est compétitive juste pour
les travailleurs et aussi raisonnables
pour les Canadiennes Canadiens on va
voir ce qui vous sépare on va
représenter le tableau on vous demande
13,5 d'augmentation
l'offre patronale est de 9%, est-ce que
vous vous avez une marge est-ce que vous
est-ce que sur ce point-là de l'argent
est-ce qu'on est pas si loin que ça
finalement comme le laissant entendre le
syndicat mais la première chose
que j'ai été malheureux mais je
négocierai pas en public alors
malheureusement je pourrais pas faire ça
mais j'aimerais quand même peut-être
informer
la dernière l'année dernière avec une
première offre sur la table et
l'Alliance a quitté la table et on est
revenu il y a deux semaines et là on a
commencé d'autres conversations on a
déposé comme la commission d'intérêts
publics avait recommandé 9 % sur 3 ans
et nous poursuivons avec la
recommandation de la Commission
d'intérêt public très bien le
télétravail chez vous vous avez été en
mesure d'entendre les questions que
j'avais pour la portion le côté syndical
on a l'impression que c'est un enjeu
vraiment important quel est votre
compréhension quel est votre demande
claire quant au télétravail qu'est-ce
que vous voulez qu'est-ce que vous
souhaitez mais je pense la première
chose c'est de se rappeler qu'on a été
obligé de travailler de la maison par
nécessité à cause de la pandémie et
quand on a commencé à pouvoir
recommencer à travailler au bureau on a
commencé à développer comme on dit le
télétravail ou modèle hybride et le
Conseil du Trésor a fait une directive
qui faisait en sorte que les employés
pouvaient travailler deux à trois jours
semaine à la maison et on voulait mettre
évidemment le meilleur des deux mondes
milieu de travail comment on peut
travailler en équipe qui a des bénéfices
de travailler au bureau mais aussi qu'il
y a des bénéfices de travailler à la
maison et donc deux à trois jours au à
la maison est possible puis on a suivi
aussi ce qui se passait avec d'autres
juridictions provinciales entre autres
le Québec vous voulez et le secteur
privé juste pour qu'on soit clair vous
voulez quand même obligé la plupart des
fonctionnaires à rentrer minimum deux
jours au bureau moi je pense pas que
c'est la question du nombre de jours
c'est plutôt la question du droit de
gestion et c'est la droit de l'employeur
de décider comment la directive va être
appliquée puis on est encore en train de
transformer le milieu du travail alors
on va voir comment va se passer les
c'est vraiment au niveau des services et
comment on les livre puis comme je vous
ai tantôt c'est le meilleur des deux
mondes des fois avoir une opportunité
évidemment pour que les gens puissent
travailler ensemble vous voulez vous
voulez des normes qui traversent toute
la fonction publique il y a une
directive présentement oui quand on a
mis en place puis que la gestion a
décidé et on va continuer à transformer
évidemment le travail et j'espère que on
va pouvoir avoir une entente évidemment
c'est une discussion qui se passe à la
table de négociation ok dernière
question et combien de temps le
gouvernement Trudeau va laisser la grève
aller compte tenu que des services aux
citoyens sont touchés c'est une très
bonne question je vous dirais que
présentement
parce que nous sommes encore à la table
on met tous nos efforts pour pouvoir
travailler jour et nuit évidemment pour
arriver à une entente puis j'espère
qu'on va pouvoir y arriver le plus tôt
possible on concentre les efforts à la
table présentement bon très bien on va
parce que Monsieur Trudeau votre patron
a dit que la patience avait des limites
moi je pense que ce qui est important
c'est qu'on est à la première journée
évidemment on veut s'assurer qu'on
regarde comment ça se passe je suis une
éternelle optimiste évidemment je suis
confiante que on a un point en commun
c'est qu'on veut s'assurer de bien
offrir les services au Canadiens
vous êtes à la table parce que ce
barrière lui avait plutôt l'impression
contraire merci beaucoup demandé de
vérifier on est à la table merci
beaucoup pour nous avoir reçu